Clotho the spinner lack assists the
alotta and atropos the inevitable three
names that might not mean a whole lot to
most people but these make up the three
sisters of fate the mirai of Amelia if
you want the Greek pronunciation the
sisters were the children of Zeus and
thermus which does explain their gift of
prophecy they may not be the exact same
thing as the Oracles but they played an
important part in helping their mother
decide the future of humanity there is
some discussion however of NYX perhaps
being the mother of the sisters but
thermos seems to be the goddess that
most poets agree on and they controlled
what was known as the thread of life
when man was created they began to spin
this thread it would then be measured
and cut which predicted someone's life
from birth to death it followed all of
the steps they took all the actions they
made in their life and all the
consequences that then followed it was
essentially prophesying of every human
life that was symbolized by pieces of
thread once you reach the end of a
thread that symbolizes the end of that
individual's life and this was thought
to be a very rigid system that could not
be cheated nor changed unless you were
Zeus of course his relationship with his
daughters meant that he could extend or
shorten the life of his allies and
enemies the Murray themselves would
rarely intervene in human affairs nor
did they choose who died and how humans
still had the freedom to influence the
details of their own death the sisters
of fate just knew when someone's time
had come to an end
they were often accompanied by several
deities and spirits and using the laws
governed by their mother thermus they
would assign the appropriate entity to
ones death if you were destined to die a
gruesome death in battle then they would
send the karez
if you committed crimes against humanity
and the gods then they would ensure that
the earrin knees were dispatched to
inflict the correct punishment and the
same can be said for birth as they were
accompanied by Ellie Thea one of the
goddesses of labor and childbirth in
terms of appearance they can sometimes
appear as young women but most of the
time they were more your stereotypical
Crone's
old ugly hags who would be seen
measuring and cutting the threads of
life sometimes all three sisters were
shown with scepters and crowns and other
times they had varying trinkets from
scales and sundials to wax tablets and
scrolls they were mentioned by numerous
poets and do feature in several stories
outside of their main duties they took
part in the war between the Giants and
the gods even killing two giants known
as soon and Agrius with the bronze maces
now this is something that I definitely
found rather amusing the image of three
elderly women who could barely walk
beaten Giants to death with maces that
they could probably just about carry
there is also some mention of the Mariah
in relation to typhoon when Zeus was in
pursuit of - the Mariah deceived him by
offering him fruit that would make him
stronger the fruit of course had no
effect and did nothing but by Zeus the
time needed to find - one of the few
times that we see the Mariah intervene
in the affair of mortals is at the
command of Hera who orders them to stop
Heracles being born with aid from
ilithyia
Heracles his mother Alka Mina is stuck
in an endless birthing process however
alchemy NIH's Midwife Galan theas visits
the Mariah telling him that it is the
will of Zeus that Heracles must be born
this distracted them long enough for
Heracles to be born but the Midwife
would pay quite a steep price for
deceiving the gods
the sisters transformed her into a
weasel for her deceit but this wouldn't
be the end of the punishment
in order to meet she would have to be
mounted through the ears and she would
give birth through her throat
essentially vomiting out children
quietly grotesque punishment and one
which shows the Mirai should not be
trifled with but I guess you also have
to give it to them for creativity it
also wasn't all bad for the Midwife
turned weasel as the goddess Hecate took
pity on her and made her one of her
sacred followers the Mariah this
interesting combination of prophecy in
life and death they have an extremely
important role that other deities may
not necessarily be trusted to perform
and for the most part they do remain
impartial if you have enjoyed the video
then leave a thumbs up and consider
hittin that notification bells so you
know when videos are uploaded as always
I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]